let's bring in the head coach of
Michigan State all he does is get to the
tournament I believe 21 consecutive
years in the NCAA tournament is that
right coaches oh don't act like you
don't know
come on okay I want to start with you
here you were a Division two
all-american right okay but you played
northern Michigan right right okay
who plays the game in the NBA the way
you played in college and he's probably
a you know Division one all-american but
were you a gunner
no I was a passer man I was a pleaser oh
I kept other guys in touch and I did the
same thing in high school I defeat
Mariucci the ball but he missed a lot of
shots so I didn't get any assists in
high school so college he was playing
football and so I didn't have to worry
about all those missed shots you have
but you were Division two all-american
yeah you know they had those Otis you
know good stats and you know I you know
I started my first start if you can
believe this was my sophomore year
against Michigan State at home Gus
kanakas Gregory Kell sir and the
lawfulness came up and northern Michigan
you think that wasn't a and you be that
was something big how did how much you
lose by you know if I had a shooting
contest between you Coach Cal and Jim
Boeheim
I think I'd win it I really do I think
I'd win it just because of my
youthfulness Coach K has a back problem
but he was a great scorer in high school
I think he led just you know city of
Chicago in scoring I know what Mike's
getting old and he's and he's and you
know he's got that back problems I don't
think he
station isn't as good so you're not
getting old
no I'm actually staying the same you
you're a division 2 guy you got to stay
the same you know and doesn't change
did you rhyme and assess keyword
division one guys did you recruit Zion
Williamson know sometimes you know you
you look at certain players and excuse
me you know you're probably not gonna
get him so that was one of them you know
I think Sian was destined for nuclear
Kentucky who else did you say like did
you recruit Kobe did you recruit Kevin
Garnett LeBron you know we didn't
recruit Kevin Garnett LeBron a little
bit we had won the national championship
when LeBron was a freshman in his high
school coaches from the state of
Michigan at that time Keith damn broad
was now the coach at Duquesne and so we
were in there a little bit and then I
saw him that summer and I realized that
there is not a chance in the world that
he's that one all right where are we
headed with the one and done rule looks
like it's changing yeah I think it's
definitely going I think all these rules
are gonna change I I just
Danah I mean there's as strongly as I
can I
III know everybody's thinking we're
giving the kids the most freedom and
it's best for them but I don't know
about you Dan but I I made a lot of
average decisions at 18 19 years old you
know and III think a lot of these kids
you know there's gonna be sullen bronze
but there's going to be a lot more that
aren't LeBrons and then what are they
going to be like in a year or two and
they don't make it so I I worry about it
I think it's going to cause a lot of
kids to kind of beg school and you know
I hear some guys talking and it's only
gonna be six or eight kids there's gonna
be a lot more than that that think
they're good enough and there'll be a
lot more agents and middlemen telling
them they're good enough and I I don't
think it's gonna affect college that
much and I'll I think it'll it'll accept
all a little bit more but I think the
biggest person it's going to sucked is
the kids themselves but you're not I
mean how many times are you recruiting
and owner at Michigan State you know
I've had three or four of them and two
of them didn't think they'd be one and
done and they ended up one and done but
I'm not recruiting many kids that you
know you go into it that way but I think
once that rule comes out there'll be a
lot more kids thinking they're one and
done and yet you know throughout most
years there's not as many that really
can do that but I think once the kids
get set on it it's kind of change you
know and it's gonna make it a little
more difficult for them and for us
yeah my only issue I'd take issue with
what you're saying is we don't care
about kids in other sports who you could
have soccer players who could be signing
you know at 10 12 years of age tennis
players do this baseball players hockey
players do this golfers do this it feels
like we're looking out for basketball
players when it it feels like that's
more of we don't want to ruin our sport
or our tournament we want to have these
stars you know I'll take somebody one
and done just so I got to see Carmelo
for one year so I don't know it feels
like we're overprotective I wouldn't
mind I wouldn't mind taking a
one-and-done so you could have them for
a year but now that won't happen it'll
be a none and done and yeah and as you
say that looking at the other side
hasn't worked out so bad for football
football players do you think the NBA
players do you hear the Commissioner
talking about you know are these young
new Millennials having any fun are they
enjoying it are they appreciating it you
know come to handle you know 50 million
dollars at 17 18 years old I can't
handle it I mean that's what exactly
what I'm saying and so I don't think we
see the studies on what it does you know
if you look at Hollywood you know those
those young stars that come out later on
in life hasn't ended up very good for a
lot of them that started really young
you know yeah and I worry the same thing
so I listen I don't care I'm a Michigan
State's gonna be standing whether we're
one and done none and done or four and
done you know but
why not why not look on the other side
of it it's no pretty good for a football
and you know those kids get a little
more mature and and they get a little
better opportunity and maybe they can
handle things a little better he's Tom
Izzo Michigan State head basketball
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
what's your best closing line you ever
had with a recruit like you ever walked
out gone I killed it yeah usually get
down on my hands and knees have you ever
cried when he lost a recruit oh yeah oh
yeah Chris Webber
I mean I'll remember it till the day I
die because I recruited him for over
four years and loved Chris and that was
one of those I was kind of young then I
was still an assistant but you know you
do get emotionally involved with some of
these kids especially if you record them
for a long time have you ever gone have
you ever waited or gone to a recruit's
house and then gone outside and then saw
like Coach K ready to come in or
something Calipari yeah I mean you know
sort the schools you know when you go
there and everybody's lining up and you
get you know different times and yes
that's not always a good feeling you
know those two guys seem to be able to
last you most of the guys they want you
know they're to me they're more honest
elections stage and I'm in a more in a
begging stage what happens when you get
to the tournament like what changes with
you and your team that we've seen these
runs out of Michigan we're not surprised
anymore somewhat well you know I do
think for the most part you know if we
can stay healthy which we last couple
years haven't been as healthy but if we
can stay healthy
I think teams you know we've gotten
better and and I think there's a culture
here where they believe they can win you
know we've gone to a final four that
gives us seven see and we've not gone as
a 1 seed so sometimes it's a coin flip
you know the one thing Dan about the
tournament boy it comes down to matchups
comes down to you know Middle Tennessee
beat us a couple of years you know which
will go beat Duke I mean sometimes team
get hot the difference to all my
football buddies you know usually in
football the bigger stronger faster
better team wins but in basketball
between a three-point shot and referees
which could eliminate guys you know in
football you can get five holding
penalties but at least our tackle is
still in the game in basketball he's out
and that makes a difference for more
upsets and more problems but we've kind
of hung in there because I think we've
got a pretty good culture where they
believe that we can do well in March
are you more apt to send a text to your
one of your former players after a good
game or a bad game they're good where my
good game no they're good game
oh I I usually send more after bad games
you know other girlfriends and and
family members are sending them after
the pit caves you know nobody likes you
after a bad game so I usually send a
text or make a call after a tough game
or maybe if a guy got injured or
something but that's kind of fun it's
been fun to follow your guys that are in
the league and it's fun that they follow
you we got some guys coming back this
weekend I think they're gonna try to
sneak in oh it's nice nice is that the
Michigan game amazing game yeah yeah by
the way Webber did say when I asked him
about you know Paulie do you have the
Chris Webber yeah coach about four years
ago we had Webber on the show and you
asked him be at a mulligan we go to
Michigan or Michigan State and Chris
Webber said quote don't do that don't do
that don't do that he said he talked
about the love he had for you because
the truth is I don't want to answer that
right now you know I did I think a great
relationship with Chris and his family
in fact his younger brother came here as
a walk-on and and still a Noma teen and
Chris are close you know and I have had
a lot of respect for Chris every started
recruiting when he was in eighth grade I
really did and had him up here in fact
Scott Skiles was playing and if he can
believe that he might've been in seventh
grade and we had him up for the last
game of the year and that's where the
recruiting started it just
then then play good enough for us but I
remained a friend to him can you confirm
this story with Scott Skiles okay
Michigan State is playing Georgetown
yeah and Skiles is dribbling by the
Georgetown bench and says to John
Thompson I need you to get a bleep and
bleep er out here who can guard me do
you want the truth
I don't know if he said that and I would
never say that to John but Scott's
crazier than that game I think he went 1
for 8 and if I recall it right in the
second half I think he was 7 for 8 and
when Scott got on a little role I was
just a ga then but when Scott got on a
little role he had a tendency to be the
Michael Jordan of his day you know he
could talk it with with anybody so it
wouldn't surprise me but I'd never say
that to John I know much respect for
John no Skiles was one of my favorite
players because he wasn't afraid of
anybody know you know I play a good
story Dan it was Valentine's Day senior
year and we're playing Iowa and I think
it was I'm trying to remember the player
and the coach now player I think was
from Michigan who played for the Bulls
very good player little guard and he
goes running out there
BJ Armstrong Armstrong yeah PJ and he
goes running out there with this big
card and they he gives the card as they
shake hands you know that's one that two
teams would alternate HSA cans at the
middle you know they don't do there
anymore but he gave Scott a card Scott
you know barber parents gave it to me
and you know what the hell's this you
know well after the game they asked the
coach you know why did he give him a
card he said well everybody else makes
Scott mad and he scores
35 so I decided to be nice to him and he
only got 25
that was a true story and is that dr.
Tom Davis no no that was Oh God
ended up going to USC mmm equality
employer no no no oh geez now if you
guys can't remember it's your guys job
to figure those things oh no no one lewd
Olsen no midnight loot George ravelin
kind of guy and he had DJ give him that
corn that card and there was a nice
Valentine's Day card he said you know
and it's true Scott Skiles to this day
was one of the few players that ever
could play mad and angry you know a lot
of guys think they can but it usually
works in their detriment he no matter he
got and the more people got on them the
Petri plate you know and so that's what
Jed got out of all the time
Riley mom hey good luck against the
Wolverines and and we'll probably talk
to you during the tournament that is if
you have a great either you bow out
earlier you have your usual tournament
run either way we'll probably check in
with you Thank You Man
that's a Thomism michigan state's head
coach yeah Scott Skiles didn't Scott
Skiles have the NBA record for most
assists in a game when he was with
Orlando like twenty four he had the
record for a while let me check okay
Continental Tire Coach's Corner proud to
be the exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive what you
drive how you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire Calm
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]